يعلم ما بين ايديهم وما خلفهم
ولا يحيطون بشيء من علمه الا بما شاء
وسيع كرسيه السماوات
لا ي حفظهما وهو
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين والصلاه والسلام على رسوله
الكريم وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا
عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعدش
الحافظ الامام مسلم رحمه الله تعالى
ان ابا جهل
عمرو بن عمرو عمرو بن عمرو بن هشام
جاء على نادي قريش
وراى النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يصلي عند
الكعبه
فقال لهم مؤنبا موبخا
ا تذرون محمدا يمرغ
خديه
بين اظهركم
ويسب الهتكم
والله لارينكم ما اصنع به غدا او ان رايته
ابو جهل
قريش
‏have and
people make
around
and
would
set up around the in the area which iser
‏and under these would sit the different
tribe leaders
right so you have these different t and
in each one they sitting
in this kind of Arabic style gathering
and each of the
t would have different gatherings in
them different tribe leaders in them and
some of the
‏more
gather
and they would
certain hours in which they would
different issues, different things would
come up, different judgs, whatever it
صلى الله عليه وسلم
مقام ابراهيم
ابراهم
الله عليه
الله سبحانه وتعالى واتخذوا
من مقام ابراهيم مصلى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
take مقام ابراهم
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ابو جهل
‏and himay
and to the leaders in this gathering and
said you would sit here and this man
pray his prayer and insult your gods in
theigion of your foras and do nothing
and not a finger to stop him
he said
فجاء من اليوم التالي
وكان اخذ ابو جهل صخره
اراد بها رد راس رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم عند بيت الله الحرام
الذي كان في الجاهليه يرى الرجل قاتل قاتل
ابيه
ولا ياخذ بثاره تعظيما للمسجد
لكن وصل بهم الحنق والحقد
بمكان
take
صلى الله عليه
‏body
even though this was the greatest sin
even in their belief but this is how
much they hated him
and so the next day came the propet
came not interfering with anyone he
would make
and he would sit there at the and people
would come to learn people come to asked
الله
ابو جهل
wasج
صلى الله عليه وسلم
فاذا بهم يرونه
ينقص
على عقبيه
فزعا
ابو جهلون
ما بك يا ابا الحكم
فقال رايت هولا
وخندقا نار واجنحه
[Silence]
direيه
قال اما لو اقترب ودنى
مني لاختطفته الملائكه عضوا عضوا
صلى الله عليه وسلم
anyer
angcked
himart
one at a time
الله سبحانه وتالى
الله
سبحانه وتعالى
ارايت الذي ينهى عبدا اذا صلى
الله
كان على الهدى او امر بالتقوى
ارايت ان كذب وتولى
هنا في التفات في الضمير يعني ابا جهل
‏otherob
يعلم بان الله يرى
الله
المفعول محذوف
ان الله يرى محذوف المفعول يعني يرى ماذا
يرى كل شيء
وهذا من اسلوب القران ان يحذف المفعول
لشمول اللفظ
‏all
these sent down after this
anotherion
ابو جه
انهك عن هذا
ان فاغلض له رسول الله الحديث في الصحيح
واغلظ له يعني انتهره النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم دفاعا عن نفسه واغلظ له
انذا بروفيت صلى الله عليه وسلم سكور
‏care
ابو جهل
انا اكبر واعظم العربي
ناديا
هساد
يعني هو قال في الروايه لفظ الروايه
اتهددني
بما تهددني يا محمد
لقد علمت قريش اني اعظم اهل الوادي ناديه
‏said what are you
me
and knows that I have the greatest coun
the powerful
in all of
in all of the greatest council
is a coun it is it means a coun of
people that when they are summoned they
are movers and shakers of the society
نادي
نادي من النداء
لان عند الشدائد ينادون
فهذا هو النادي
[Silence]
فانزل الله
فليدع ناديه
سندعو الزبانيه
كلا تطعه واسجد واقترب
ان سوى الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏Let himon
and we will summon
the angels of hell to take him and
these are the angels that special in the
torture of the damned.
‏angell
[Silence]
جاء بالسين
التي تدل على المستقبل القريب
فليدعو ناديه سندعو الزبانيه
كلا تطعه واسجد واقترب فجاء عن النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم انه قال اما انه لو دعا
ناديه
وقت اذ
لاخذته الزبانيه
الله سبحانه وتعالى
سوره اقرا
‏inatellجود
[Silence]
صلاه هنا كلمه قوله واسجد امر ضرب السجود
يعني السجود وحده هكذا اسجد لحاله لا
بمعنى صلي
بزياده توكيد السجود ويجوز
الامر بركن من الاركان والمقصود به
الكل مثل وقران الفجر فهو من ذكر من باب
ذكر الشيء ببعض اركانه
ان سوى الله سبحانه وتعالى
سجود
الله وهذا يدل على قول النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم
اقرب ما يكون العبد من ربه وهو ساجد
الله
سجود
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده
ان يبارك لنا في القران العظيم اساله
تعالى ان ينفعني واياكم بما فيه من الايات
والذكر الحكيم اساله سبحانه وتعالى ان
يجمعنا جميعا مع المصطفى
صلى الله عليه وسلم في جنات النعيم مع
صحابته والصالحين والشهداء
والصديقين
والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
ان شاء الله سوره المدثر
اقرا ان شاء الله
سوره